7.6 billion dollars 7 800 jobs ended
three years of time this is how much
Microsoft lost on their worst
acquisition of all time Nokia in
retrospect this was an obvious disaster
just waiting to happen Microsoft had
taken a gamble with a legacy phone maker
that was struggling to keep up with the
modern world of smartphones and
unfortunately for Microsoft things
didn't play out in their favor
but what if I told you that there was
more to the story than just a misguided
acquisition with a bunch of money you
see The Bleak state of Nokia isn't just
obvious in hindsight it was obvious in
real time as well in fact investors were
largely against the acquisition the day
that the deal was finalized Microsoft
shares fell six percent losing the
company 15 billion dollars in market
value or over twice the price of Nokia
why you ask well the writing was already
on the wall for Nokia Not only was there
market share and the brand presence
collapsing but they had lost 4 billion
dollars the previous year
so Microsoft was having to massively
subsidize their operations just to own
the company hearing this you're probably
thinking that Microsoft must have been
real desperate to get into the phone
market and you're right they were really
desperate but what if I told you that
there was more to the story what if I
told you that Microsoft was actually
blackmailed into buying Nokia nothing
straight up illegal went down but Nokia
very much leveraged their position and
the power over Microsoft within the
phone market the force a 7.2 billion
dollar deal down their throat so join me
as we take a look at how one of the
biggest companies in the world got
blackmailed into making the worst
acquisition of their history
thank you
taking a look back Microsoft's foray
into the smartphone industry can
actually be traced all the way back to
early 2004 to a project named Photon the
goal of photon was to create a mobile
version of Windows that would be
launched by the end of 2007. to be
honest Photon didn't look all that great
but with that being said Microsoft was
very much ahead of the curve with
smartphones the problem though was that
they didn't stay ahead of the curve
Photon ended up being one of those
projects that kept being delayed time
after time because frankly Photon was
just a side project that Microsoft
didn't really care about that was until
2007 when Apple would reveal the iPhone
on the outside Microsoft would put up a
brave front and act like they didn't
care about the iPhone in fact Steve
Ballmer the CEO of Microsoft at the time
would actually laugh at the iPhone and
claim that it didn't appeal to business
customers
[Music]
fully subsidized with a plan I said that
is the most expensive phone in the world
and it doesn't appeal to business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard which makes it not a very good
email machine but while Microsoft acted
it like they didn't care internally they
were scrambling
they would reorganize their entire
mobile team and start working on a new
operating system this was basically code
for putting lipstick on photon and
shipping it as the next big thing but
there's a tough took way longer than
expected in fact they would end up
rushing out a beta version of this in
2009 dubbed Windows mobile 6.5 Microsoft
was very much hoping that the windows
name would carry this product but that
simply wasn't enough users would see you
right through this crappy software and
even Steve bomber would end up admitting
that they screwed up you would think
that this failure would lead to
Microsoft to re-evaluating their
position and approaching the smartphone
market from a different approach but
Microsoft simply doubled down you see
Microsoft very much had it tunnel vision
all they could see was that Apple and
Google already had solid products on the
market well they didn't
so their number one goal was to just to
get the market as soon as possible and
unfortunately this led to yet another
crappy launch with Windows phone 7.
during the announcement Microsoft would
proudly tell the world that they had
struck deals with many of the world's
largest manufacturers this included Dell
Garmin Asus HTC HP LG Samsung Sony and
Toshiba Microsoft was so confident in
the Windows Phone 7 that they would
actually stage a funeral for the iPhone
but when the Windows Phone 7 actually
made it to the market it was clear that
Microsoft had cut a lot of corners the
phone didn't support copy pasting custom
ringtones tethering multitasking or even
traditional notifications Microsoft
didn't think they needed notifications
because of their cool little window
tiles but the public didn't agree and
they weren't the only ones after seeing
how Windows Phone 7 turned out half of
Microsoft's Hardware Partners were the
back out of the deal honestly I think
the only reason the other half moved
forward was to stay on good terms with
Microsoft but this wasn't enough to
cover for Microsoft's shortcomings to
make things worse developer support for
Windows phones was atrocious developers
would usually just start with iOS then
move on to Android and then just skip
Windows and given that third-party apps
make the experience for most people a
lack of third-party apps made the
Windows Phone an absolute no-go if this
was anyone else this right here is where
their journey within the smartphone
market would have come to an end
but since we're talking about Microsoft
they would have the money and resources
to throw one last Hail Mary
given the topic of the video I'm sure
you guessed that Nokia was the hail Mary
but this actually played out a lot
differently than you might think you see
Microsoft didn't just immediately move
to binocchia in fact they didn't really
want to own Nokia all they were looking
for was a rock solid partnership and as
such they would send a trojan horse to
Nokia in late 2010 in the form of
Stephen elop elop was the president of
Microsoft's business division which at
the time was producing record profits so
he was in a pretty comfortable position
but for whatever reason in September of
2010 elap would take a job offer from
Nokia to become their CEO from the very
beginning this deal seemed fishy why
would the leader of the largest division
of the largest software company in the
world leave to join a dying Giant and it
was just as fishy from Nokia's
perspective as well elop was their first
non-finished CEO in their 145 year
history and to give elopt his job they
had to fire a man who had been with them
for 30 years
so surely there was more to the story
than just Steven being a good candidate
was Microsoft and Nokia secretly
planning a partnership to take on Google
and apple well yes that's exactly what
they're planning just a couple of months
after Steven became CEO they would
publicly announce that Nokia was going
to exclusively sell Windows phones Nokia
was betting it all instead of going down
the proven path of selling Androids
Nokia had chosen to take a gamble with
the windows but the allegiance to
Microsoft went much deeper than just
running Windows Nokia would basically
become a subsidiary of Microsoft as they
would support everything Microsoft for
example they would choose to integrate a
bing instead of Google they would choose
to integrate Bing Maps instead of Google
Maps and they would ditch their own app
store in favor of the Windows phone
store they basically became the go to
Windows Phone maker and they were
decently rewarded for it unit sales
would rocket nearly 10 million per
quarter but in the grand scheme of
things this was still a massive step
down for the phone giant that was Nokia
in fact calling it a step down itself
was an understatement thus Nokia was
getting obliterated during elop's tenure
Nokia stock price crashed 62 percent
their mobile phone market share halved
their smartphone market share fell from
33 to 3 and the company lost 4.9 billion
euros likely the best evidence of just
how bad things were though was this
leaked Memo from elop elop would compare
Nokia to a burning oil platform and the
claim that Nokia had to jump into the
icy water to have any chance at survival
this metaphorical jump was partnering
with Microsoft and going all in on the
Windows phone but this wasn't quite
playing out as they expected what Nokia
needed was a savior and who better to
save them than Microsoft Nokia had a bed
at all with the windows so it was only
fair that Microsoft returned a favor and
bet it all with Nokia but while that
sounded nice on paper elap knew that he
needed something more than just a good
fate to get Microsoft to buy into a
growing Money Pit and with that began
the bid to sell off Nokia
[Music]
elop didn't just jump straight into
threatening Microsoft rather it's likely
that he started off with a Motorola sort
of approach it if you didn't know around
the same time Google would require
Motorola for a ridiculous 12 and a half
billion dollars on paper this was a
terrible deal as Google would end up
losing billions but that was just on
paper the reality was that Google
actually gained something invaluable
from Motorola there are over 20 000
granted and depending patents it's a
really long story and I have a full
video about it but essentially Google
would use these patents to save Android
from litigation from Apple and Microsoft
seeing this elop likely thought about
pulling the same thing over on Microsoft
given that Nokia had way more patents
over 90 000 to be precise but there was
one fatal flaw with the strategy
Microsoft wasn't desperate to save
themselves from a lawsuit like Google
was I mean they were literally suing
Google with patents that they already
had so for elop it was back to the
drawing board and this is when elap
realized that wahi may not be able to
bribe Microsoft into buying Nokia he
could afford foreign
became the go-to Windows phone
manufacturer other manufacturers had
slowly stepped away in fact by 2013
Nokia controlled a 90 of the Windows
phone market so why not threaten to move
to Android and that's exactly how things
played out in early 2013 Nokia would
have publicly announced that they were
considering a move to Android to be
honest this was an easy out for
Microsoft they could have just let Nokia
move on to Android except that they had
already lost the smartphone Wars and
move on with their lives but instead
Microsoft would freak out that they were
about to lose their last chance to win
smartphones and they would end up
prematurely buying Nokia's phone
business for 7.2 billion dollars this
was honestly a genius move by elop as he
would brilliantly make his way back to
Microsoft as an executive after having a
terrible run at Nokia in fact elop is
still at Microsoft today serving as
their Executive Vice President so looks
like things played out pretty well for
elop but the same could not be said
about Microsoft or Nokia's phone
business you see just a couple of months
after Microsoft required Nokia Microsoft
would get a new CEO Satya Nadella from
day one Satya sanokia for exactly what
it was a desperate attempt by Steve
Ballmer to salvage an already lost
industry so instead of focusing his
efforts on Windows phones Satya would
focus on the Azure and the Enterprise
side of Microsoft and once he had enough
results to show shareholders from that
side of Microsoft he would ruthlessly
incinerate Microsoft's phone business he
would sell off the remaining parts of
Nokia lay off thousands of Nokia
employees and write off 7.6 billion
dollars in losses keep in mind they only
paid 7.2 billion for the business so
they essentially wrote off the entire
amount and another 400 million on top of
that yeah I don't think it's
controversial to say that this was by
far Microsoft's worst acquisition and it
was all because they let the threat of
Nokia to Android get their head unlike
Microsoft's bet with Nokia gurus bet
with Motorola may have been their best
bet of all time check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]